how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some ant
man 3 news we have some news about the
production of ant-man 3
when it's supposed to start and when we
can expect to actually see ant-man 3
on the big screen and then of course we
have an ant-man 3
plot leak a plot leak that involves a
new hero a new villain
and the young avengers as many as
predicted for a very
long time now especially after avengers
end game the next ant-man film is going
to be a pretty pivotal movie for
setting up the young avengers especially
with cassie lang scott lang's daughter
who goes on to be stature in the comics
so we'll talk about these new reports of
the production of ant-man 3 and break
down this new plot lake including the
new characters and new
villain a villain that links back to
phase 2
of the marvel cinematic universe but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you stay up to date on everything
relating to the mcu and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a dr
doom funko pop all you have to do to
enter subscribe to my channel like this
video and leave a comment about the
video down below
so recently fans were kind of confused
and kind of disappointed because
not too long ago michael douglas in an
interview was talking about ant-man 3
and he said that we'd have some news
relatively soon but unfortunately we
really haven't heard much in regards to
ant-man 3.
now of course during the time that we're
in right now it's rather difficult for
all of the studios
because they've had to put a lot of
projects on hold but marvel studios
reshuffled their entire phase 4
lineup including some movies that aren't
a part of phase 4 like captain marvel 2
but we got no word about ant-man 3. that
is until
now recently charles murphy of murphy's
multiverse.com shared a little bit of
information that he heard in regards to
ant-man 3 and its starting production
and charles murphy says as of now
ant-man 3 has been rescheduled to begin
production in
june of 2021 in atlanta
so that's just a little less than a year
away from now
and as far as when to expect the actual
film hitting theaters if everything goes
back to normal
he says ant-man 3 has not been canceled
and
is absolutely still in the plans if by
some miracle
everything stays on track and long-term
shutdowns are avoided
we could see ant-man 3 in theaters late
2022 or
early 2023 which is kind of great news
because obviously we have to get through
marvel's phase four before we go on to
the projects that are not a part of
phase four so
late 2022 or early 2023 is pretty good
news for the ant-man fans
and speaking of some good news we have a
plot leak for ant-man 3 today
now this plot leak was discovered by
screengeek.com and like with all leaks
they could be true or they may not be
true so
take it with a grain of salt but as most
of you know we have discovered many true
plot leaks
on my channel including some for
avengers infinity war and
avengers endgame you never know but
let's dive into this ant-man 3 plot leak
so it starts off by saying ant-man 3
will be about
cassie leaving her family to be an
avenger with scott and hope trying to
stop her
now this is something that's actually
been brought up several different times
now in ant-man and the wasp
we saw a young cassie who wanted to be a
superhero she wanted to help her father
fight crime now of course obviously she
was too young at that point in time but
then in avengers in-game we see
a more grown up cassie lane
[Music]
now this adds up with everything that
we've heard before about cassie lang
what we've heard in the past is that
cassie now wants to be a superhero
following in her father's footsteps but
her father
and hope do not want to let her
obviously as any good parents would not
let their children go out and take on
super villains but apparently this movie
is going to be about her
kind of running away from them going to
be an avenger and them trying to stop
her now of course cassie is not going to
initially go on to join
the normal avengers she's going to join
the young avengers and in the comics she
plays a pretty important role on the
team of the young avengers as
stature now it sounds like we could be
getting a little bit of the story from
the comics in the comics her parents
really don't want her to have anything
to do with the avengers but cassie
idolizes the heroes especially after
watching her father as ant-man but she
begins to experiment with some pym
particles that she takes from her father
cassie plans on escaping and running
away to join marvel's runaways but then
she discovers the young avengers and she
would eventually go on to join
them so it definitely sounds like
ant-man 3 will set
up the young avengers with cassie going
off on her own trying to be a superhero
then maybe by the end of the movie
figuring out that there is a young
avengers team after all we do have
wiccan
and speed the daughter of wanda and
vision coming in the one division series
we have kate bishop coming in to take on
the mantle of hawkeye
everyone expects iron lad to come in
then there's hulkling and of course we
know about miss marvel
so the young avengers team is there
they're going to come into the mcu it's
only a matter of time and it looks like
ant-man 3 is going to be one of the
films that set that team up so
in ant-man 3 we're going to have cassie
lang run off and try to be a hero
on her own but of course she's going to
need help from her father
scott lang aka ant-man and janet van
dyne
the wasp cassie will most likely get in
over her head and then of course ant-man
and the wasp are gonna have to come in
and help and speaking of them
needing to help her they do talk about
the villain in this league as well
they say that as far as the leak goes
the villain of ant-man 3
is modoc and if you're unfamiliar with
who he is he was once
george tarleton a man of unspectacular
intelligence who was used by the
terrorist organization
aim or aim which stands for advanced
idea mechanics and he was used in
experiments to enhance
mental powers and modoc is actually an
acronym that stands for mental organism
designed
only for killing now there are some
really important things to note here
about this villain
and about aim we have had several rumors
that modoc
will be entering the mcu pretty soon and
it just so happens that the director and
screenwriters for ant-man 3
have publicly stated their interest in
having him in the film
and aim already exists in the mcu and
this is the really important part
because we have it in the past in the
mcu in phase two and we've actually
already seen it in phase four
in a trailer now if you recall back in
iron man 3 back in phase 2 they
mentioned
aim aldrich killian was actually running
that faction
and of course if you've seen the movie
you know that they've already begun to
do
experiments on actual individuals all
the way back then
so aim has existed in the marvel
cinematic universe for
several years now and we know that
marvel loves to tie
everything back together marvel plans
ahead
years and years in advance and they
plant seeds very early on that finally
sprout
later on years later so they're
definitely going to be referencing these
events of iron
man 2 plus not to mention the mandarin
the real mandarin is coming in shang chi
and the legend of the 10 rings and of
course we had that fake mandarin in iron
man 3 as well
so ant-man and the wasp are definitely
going to have some call backs to iron
man
3. and as i mentioned before we've
actually seen aim
in a phase 4 project already because
we've seen
aim in one of the trailers for black
widow it's in the final trailer for
black widow or what they were calling
the final trailer at the time as we know
that there are actually two more
trailers coming relatively soon but it's
in the scene where yelena belova
natasha's sister in the film is strapped
down to a table
[Music]
i should have come back for you so just
based off of the clip you probably have
missed it but it was actually charles
murphy who discovered it in the past
and he said through the magic of
flipping the picture you might see the
word
aim above elena's noggin this is almost
certainly
after the big final fight since she's
wearing the same
outfit and as you can see if we freeze
this picture and we take a look you can
see the words
aim right next to her and she also
happens to be on
an operating table and in this same
scene we see somebody about to give her
a shot
she also has lines upon her head which
lead people to believe that
maybe a face swap is happening here but
that's a video for another day
the point is we clearly see the word aim
right next to her in this scene and it
looks like
it's aim who's going to be operating on
her and whatever is happening here
confirming that aim definitely still
does exist in the marvel cinematic
universe so aim has existed
and has been doing experiments on people
since iron man 3
back in phase 2 and now we have proof of
them being
in phase 4. so this does clearly make it
a perfect setup for
modok to enter in ant-man 3. in fact in
ant-man and the wasp there was the
mention of a mysterious
benefactor and we never found out who
that was and marvel would not mention
somebody like that
just to keep him in the dark and never
explain who he was he's definitely going
to be brought into light and most likely
in ant-man 3 because they mentioned him
in ant-man and the wasp so many people
right now do believe that this
mysterious benefactor could be
modok and this is going to be the main
villain in ant-man and the wasp and
stature as people are calling it right
now let's face it that title just makes
sense but this will be the villain that
cassie will initially go after herself
but of course will eventually need the
help of her father
scott lang aka ant-man and janet van
dyne aka
the wasp so if all this comes true and
all of it does seem to line up so it
looks like it probably will we're going
to get a new character in the form of
scott lang's daughter cassie lang
taking on her superhero role of stature
and we're going to get a new villain
modoc the mental organism designed only
for killing
so let me know what do you think about
this plot league is this something that
you would like to see in
ant-man 3 let me know what you think
about it in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the marvel cinematic
universe
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof